fear and disbelief in her now people
gather to stand up to hate and
xenophobia one of the mourners Germany's
president I'm standing with people who
are threatened by hate and violence
together we stand side by side against
violence and language and that degrades
and excludes people that all too often
paves the way for violent acts one night
earlier in Hana a 43 year old German
national killed nine people on a
shooting rampage most of them of Turkish
and Kurdish descent the suspect was
later found dead in his home his mother
also shot dead he was a member of a gun
club and was not on the authorities
radar Germany's Attorney General has
taken over the investigation he said the
suspect wanted to send a provocative
message oh they are homepage the
suspects web page contained a video
message the kind of manifesto at
manifest
Angus belt they're full of confused
thoughts and conspiracy theories also
profoundly racist mindset you see no
allies in Berlin Chancellor Angela
Merkel condemned the violence racism is
a poison hate is a poison and this
poison exists in our society and is
responsible for far too many crimes we
don't distinguish citizens according to
their background or religion we stand
with all our strength and determination
against all those who try to divide
Germany last night in CET
Berlin is gathered at the Brandenburg
Gate to show solidarity with the victims
even more marched through the
multicultural district no cone to show
their courage anger and grief one of
those injured is a good friend of mine
what has happened has really affected me
the bar was a place I had often been to
it gives me heartache we've experienced
violence in our countries we've come to
Germany as refugees only to experience
it again here in Germany and that really
hurts the problem is getting worse but
Germany is a rich country things are
good here and in the state of Hesse and
- I really don't understand it
many are demanding answers as to how
right-wing terror has been able to
spread in recent years the killings have
completely shaken ha now the city has a
population of about 100,000 with a wide
range of ethnic backgrounds the
confederation of Kurds in Germany has
confirmed that several of the dead did
have Kurdish origins we met with some of
the family members of those killed in
the attacks many members of the Kurdish
community have gathered at this cultural
center on the outskirts of Hanau in
shock and in solidarity with a family
who lost their eldest son on Wednesday
night the grieving mother and father of
the victim needed medical attention
they haven't slept since they learnt
about the death of their son ferret one
close relative tells us what happened in
the shisha bar this man Kazu farad is my
cousin
I only know I got a call at 11:00 p.m.
from his friends that he was taken from
us he was about to leave the bar just
wanted to finish his meal he had just
passed his exams a week ago we were
going to work together we've been
talking about that a lot
w bar what upsets him and many here is
that they are still seen as Outsiders
despite living in her now for
generations
his grandfather came here in the 50s as
a construction worker and helped build
here now his father grew up here
her heart was born here he graduated and
went to a German school that's the only
thing that differentiated him from the
Germans is how he looked if now we are
just reduced to the way we look that has
nothing to do with democracy across town
at a youth project NASM Turin echoes
that view xenophobia has reached the
center of our society and we Germans
with a migration background we feel this
mostly I feel German I was born here but
I see from my appearance that others the
real Germans I think I don't belong here
it's just so sad that's all colic
preparing placards for a vigil in her
now NASM and his friends were shocked
when they first heard of the attack it
happened in their shisha bar in the city
centre it's a place they regularly meet
and hang out at the shisha bar two weeks
ago we were there with friends smoking
shisha man today it makes me tremble it
could have been me my sister - Vesta
nauseum told us three people he knew
lost a close relative in the shooting
and that terrorist attacks always seemed
like something that happened to other
people but sadly now it's a reality that
has touched many here let's talk more
about this now with DWS political
correspondent Hass Braun joining me here
in the studio and DW correspondent our
pod so see on the ground for us in ha
now our pod can you tell us where you
are right now and and what's happening
this morning in Hana yes I'm in front of
the first shooting area which was the
midnight sports
are directly behind me to my right and
it's still a cordoned off area and order
an area under investigation by the
police and for us forensic investigators
and they're still looking at any
possible clues that will give them a
very exact timeline of the shooter and
his actions a couple of days ago when he
started on his rampage at about ten
minutes after 10:00 in the evening
Central European Time and they're also
interviewing people and they're talking
to some of the survivors who are
recovering from their wounds in a
hospital they're all trying to put
together a picture of things and now we
also have some information about some of
the victims I can confirm now as we
heard and report most of the victims
were of Turkish origin but not all for
example there is a Romanian national now
confirmed the Romanian Foreign Ministry
has confirmed that German authorities
have told them that one of the victims
is a Romanian national he comes from
guru view Georgiou rather in Romania
he's 23 years old his name is villi
Pound and the tragedy is that he and his
family moved here to Germany to start a
new life he was the the parents only
child and what had happened was he was
shot literally in front of that midnight
sports bar he had stepped out of his car
just finished his work as a courier and
the shooter had apparently just seen him
as he was about to get into his own car
and decided he looks a little bit
foreign shot him dead the man didn't
even know what was happening didn't know
that there had been a shooting just
seconds earlier in the midnight sports
bar so a tragedy all around haunts there
there's been an outpouring of public
sympathy for what's happened is this in
many ways a watershed moment for the
country several politicians have
described it as that certainly it is a
an incident of an almost unprecedented
arity in in Germany it has been many
years since we had this this many dead
in a similar sort of incident of
right-wing extremist violence and it was
a moment at least in which Joe and
political life came to a SAN story as
today a moment of reflection also about
where the country is situated at the
moment what is happening in the country
weather
indeed it will can be described as a
watershed I guess we can only say after
a while to see whether there was a clear
before and after this incident whether
as a result of this incident the way
politics works the way radical
right-wing extremism is combatted in
Germany and so on whether those things
are going to change but certainly it was
a moment a very somber moment and a
moment of reflection and stance tour in
German political life the country's
Attorney General has taken on the
investigation now and it's treating this
as a case of domestic terrorism and not
looking so much as into the attack is
being motivated by racial hatred which
it was more of domestic terrorism what's
the distinction between the two well the
very fact that the federal prosecutor
has taken this case on indicates that it
is regarded as a case that has
significance for Germany as a whole and
is regarded as a potential threat to the
German state or to stability in Germany
in other words that it is a potentially
terrorist attack whether one defines it
as that in a kind of legal sense I think
depends to some extent on whether this
person was acting on his own whether he
was acting on the basis of a clear
political ideology whether he was bound
into a kind of network whether there
were supporters people that he talked to
possibly people who knew beforehand
whether though this was going to happen
several politicians have called it a
terror act an act of terror
an act of terrorism and certainly that's
been the effect on parts of the society
but I think in legal terms those people
like the federal prosecutor who have to
deal with the legal issues are careful
at the moment to call it that precisely
a terrorist act ok this potential act of
terrorism is being looked into as United
all of the country's major political
parties against the far-right populist
alternative for Germany party the AFD
let's listen to what the leader of the
governing Christian Democrats had to say
about the AFD after the shootings of
what the perpetrator is judged to have
been
it appears evident that he was motivated
by racist and anti-foreigner views and
that amounts to a far-right motivation
and that strengthens my position that
the CDU and not just the CDU but all
political parties in Germany must always
adamantly oppose any collaboration with
a political party that at least in part
tolerates right-wing extremists and I
have no problem saying Nazis in its own
ranks
and which plants the seed in the
national political landscape for
precisely this kind of ideology fuga no
jesus hunts the AFD is the third largest
party in the german parliament is any
cooperation with the AFD now unlikely
for the foreseeable future well it was
unlikely before this incident the
christian democrat the conservative
party of Angela Merkel and I'm the Great
Khan Canberra who we've just heard have
a party Congress decision that they are
not going to cooperate with the AFT but
against the background of this action of
this of these murders of this terror
attack it has become even more unlikely
impossible to cooperate with this party
their alternative for Germany party says
that this incident is being
instrumentalized to gain political
points against it but one has to say
this party has based its own policies on
anti-foreigner sentiment on criticizing
the democratic processes in this country
of on questioning the legitimacy of
people like Angela Merkel being transfer
in this country and there are is a part
in this party that certainly are as
we've just heard in this clip that
certainly are Nazis that are people that
want to establish a kind of Nazi state
in Germany and certainly those are kind
of sentiments that are reflected in this
in the ideology that the attacker in
Hinault actually supported and put down
in his manifesto so there certainly some
kind
ideological connection between what the
AFD stands for and what this action this
terrorist act this racist act was based
on art what are people saying where you
are in Hanna about what needs to change
what needs to happen in light of these
shootings they need more security they
need to know that they are welcome here
a lot of these people are second
generation Germans in other words their
parents came from other countries and
settled here or they were children when
they came here they grew up here this is
this is their country also and they want
to have they want to know that that is
respected and looked at by everyone I
mean on Thursday a German president
frankfurter Steinmeier said be careful
what you say be careful about your
language he was addressing everyone in
the country because of the sensitivities
and about how things can be taken badly
in the wrong they taken as a wrong
opinion and also influenced other people
about you know perhaps going right-wing
so everyone has to be careful and now
today later on today at 2 o'clock in the
afternoon there is going to be a
demonstration against what has happened
against racism here in the city where
people are trying to come together and
find some sanity in a situation that is
anything but ok we'll have more on that
demonstration coming up later today in
hat out for now Arpad so see in hah no
thanks for very much in hasta pronto
here in the studio Thanks